jobs are super important maybe like the
jobs that we do just really runs Society
you know they say in the media like we
have all these like boss
or whatever and but then it's like okay
when the rubber meets the road at these
big companies these companies are about
to build out of business right and they
have to fire all the people they don't
need you know who gets fired I hate to
say it guys it's a lot of white women in
HR I'll tell you that but no I'm serious
I started looking at it the before and
after of Elon Musk like before he had
this really diverse group of people and
then he was like all right we gotta make
money now ladies ladies you gotta go